ich kann schon mal ganz kurz einem
relikt zeigen und zwar ich habe mich
über die mode informiert gerade halbe
stunde lang
ich werde jetzt mit dinos anfangen hallo
ich meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy ich bin
vielleicht ein wenig vom licht her über
steuert das ist ganz einfach kommen
softbox an macht und auf einmal
verschwindet die ganze sonne
das war so ein bisschen creepy gerade
und es ist doch klar immer wenn ich auf
den server gehe ist gerade nacht oder
geht die sonne auf
ich weiß es nicht ich mache mal ganz
kurz wieder hier in mich ich habe mich
super toll vorbereitet auf diese folge
jetzt ernsthaft also jetzt nicht
irgendwie ironisch gemeint oder so ich
will richtig viel schaffen
der ist letzte von mike hayes was ich
vorgelesen habe den tipp war zwar ganz
cool für ein anfang aber er hat ende
leider falsch geschrieben jetzt mit es
geschrieben in seiner nachricht er hat
calculator geschrieben der stadt
kultiviert
hier wird einfach mal so ein tutorial
von motoren an den kopf von das kalter
und habe jetzt hier so ein paar sachen
aus gefunden zwar dass dieser dna eine
leise aber komplett falsch ist und ich
musste mir einen ende leiser mitmachen
weil ich hab mir schon so ein paar dinge
hier aufgeschrieben die ich hier so
machen wollte und zwar möchte ich in
dieser folge wenn alles gut klappt kann
ich schon das erste kino i schlüpfen
lassen dafür sortiere ich aber erstmal
ganz kurz mal inventar weil ich brauche
dafür ein paar alte das heißt ich bin
jetzt echt ich bin mir jetzt echt ich
will hier jetzt mal was reißen wenn ich
schon relativ früh für mich und projekt
das ist für entscheidungen im rat war
hier ein bisschen bad übrigens ich wurde
wieder hart beleidigt in den kommentaren
von wegen informier dich doch mal gesagt
ihr könnt mir kommentar schreiben der
sieht doch schon super kommentare
angekommen allerdings finde ich doch
immer noch ein wenig traurig wenn dann
leute schreiben
du kannst ja gar nix ja ich bin zurzeit
aber wirklich jeden tag verdienen wie
gar nicht zu hause aber darum soll es
gar nicht gehen sondern es soll darum
gehen dass ich jetzt gar keinen bock
habe meinen anteil weiter zu sortieren
sondern nicht mehr direkt den muss
eine leise dafür brauche ich viel eisen
die habe ich schon im inventar 1234
mir wurde auch ein super langer
kommentar geschrieben vom
kommentarschreiber weiß ich gar nicht
gegen 61 zeilen lang und beinhaltet alle
sachen die ich mit dem soll wenn ich in
höhlen bin auf jeden fall super geil
sagt kuhl hat mich sehr gefreut
allerlei sei ein relikt ein bio fossil
und ein bio fossil soldat muss jetzt mal
ganz kurz hier in kraft das muss ich
jetzt mal ganz dafür verschwenden die
meiner biobio fossilien die einzigen ich
habe weil ich brauche diese neue leiter
der anderen relativ schwer jetzt relativ
easy ich lasse ihn als maler stehe das
nicht cool auch wenn ich da so ein paar
maschinen stehen habe von den ende
leider habe ich jetzt noch ein kalter
kulti weiter heißt er nämlich den muss
ich nach kräften dafür brauche ich
erstmal vier glas da kann ich eigentlich
die glas nehmen die ich hier noch nie
gemacht habe als 234 auch verdammt jetzt
ist das ja alles wieder sortiert ich
hasse das immer dass das nicht so
automatisch gleich so kacke sortiert
hier vier glas habe ich wasser drei
eisen man jetzt wie ich ja fair gekommen
hier wasser drei eisen jetzt brauche ich
noch keck screen dafür brauche ich blaue
blumen habe ich endlich blaue blumen und
da habe ich gelbe blumen mit gelben
blumen das ist schon mal sehr sehr schön
gelbe blumen das heißt ja dass da ich
schon mal und ich bereue ich wäre fast
wieder runtergeflogen wings die nächste
folge wird stark sein falls euch darauf
freut viele denken aber doch wir sind im
übelsten bedenken irgendwie sehr sehr
viele ach guck mal hier stehen ihre
blaue blume war der moment moment
kann ich zu führen und das aufzugehen
machen kann ich nicht dann bräuchte ich
doch nicht dass das für blaue blumen da
sind die blaue blume meine min jetzt
muss ich übrigens auch mal wieder bald
an statuen dass ich mir noch ein paar
fossilien vielleicht ausgegraben so und
jetzt fahre ich die kuh es geht doch
alles
da habe ich dir dahin schon
rausgeschmissen mio
was weggeschmissen ist ja stark so und
das oder bekomme ich green day und jetzt
mache ich das muss ich auch noch zu ende
bauen oder habe ich dass die schon zu
ende gebaut
ich habe immer das gefühl dass wir hier
irgendwer wirklich alles kaputt macht so
drei eisen da kommt ein wassereimer dann
nehme ich hier mal das glas einfach und
hier das dann bekomme ich mich an kuwait
an dem ich wieder mit kleinen spaß dies
heute mal nicht so dass ich über ihn
weiß rede sondern dass ich wirklich
diesmal protective bin froh dass es
wieder meine krims krams kiste da packt
jetzt erst mal die ganze scheiße hier
rein
das muss sie bald alles endlich muss so
viel machen in diesem projekt ich will
so viel machen ich kann schon mal ganz
kurz einem relikt zeigen und zwar ich
habe mich über die mode informiert
gerade halbe stunde lang
ich werde jetzt mit dinos anfang darauf
werde ich mich als erstes konzentrieren
und zwar den kalt werden kann hierdurch
streit habe ich auch und zwar kann ich
fossilien und diese relikte
das sind sachen die aus den fossil erz
blöcken rauskommen kann ich hier einfach
rheins tun dann geht das hier so einfach
flöten also da kann ich jetzt beispiel
eine religion oder einen fossilen und
dann kommt hier besteht eine 25
prozentige chance dass dort etwas
rauskommt was anfang an die chance
verpasst jetzt kommt nicht einfach nur
sex préval raus ich gehe aber mal ganz
kurz in der höhle und schau mal her fand
ich einen komischen starb hier mit und
will meine minions bei ihnen die wieder
an schlüssel bekommen hier
rusal dir hallo hallo
wie soll ich da nur ein minister nur
einer war egal die andere menschen
gekommen ich sterbe wegen hunger sehr
sehr geil debatte wohl dass ich die denn
jetzt mal graben hier wird er überall
schon gramm sehr traurig das ist alles
so in meiner in die direkt neben meinem
stil gemacht wird direkt nebenan zu
schönen zuhause egal ich glaube ich
lasse jetzt einfach mal wo soll ich den
im agrar belassen
durch lassen wir hier einfach glauben
kommt ihr hin ich verstehe nicht warum
nur ein haben die allerdings wie tod
oder mit gemeinschaft dann fand man ihm
irgendwie sehr schade dass ich nur allen
ab es sind zwar cool
jetzt ins 3
ok kraus ich brauche mal eben ganz
normale kiste da macht man hier eben 14
das hat schon etwas vergräbt die aber
seine linie so dann mache ich euch hier
eben ein world fable mach ich mal
hierhin noch eine kiste wie ihre tollen
sachen rein packt das verstehe ich nicht
früher ging es immer so dass sie die
sache nicht direkt in die kiste getan
haben sondern ok ok jakomini
gemeinschaft
die machen schon hier gegen die
packender scholli die machen das schon
sehr gut
was soll ich denn jetzt mal ab ich
wollte die die sollen wir das wollen die
sollen wir fossilien holen ich stütze
jetzt einfach mal hier rein monster's
ball stark das sind
habe ich ein buch heraus bekommen dass
er schon mal super dass dann woraus
bekommen wer mit dem buch kann ich mir
eine den op die abbauen und mit dem dino
pda kann ich sehen wenn ich ein dino
habe wie praxis also wie viel prozent
von dem dino als schon fertig ist und
das ist ja mein ziel dass ich bekomme
ich höre schon lava sehr sehr geil ich
brauche aber keine lava ich brauche
einfach nur fossilien wasserfall
ich will ich will aber alle gar nicht
ich will einfach nur fossilien und dafür
ist es am besten wenn ich wirklich
einfach in eine schlucht rheingold
könnte ich mir aber noch mitnimmt gold
ist nämlich für alles wichtig was
transportiert wie danke an alle
fleißigen kommentarschreiber ich könnte
das ganze auch wenn diese wenn euch
diese funktion mit der youtube
kommentarfunktion ist manchmal ein
bisschen gerettet
ich könnte das auch alles per mail an
kontraste gmail.com schreiben das ist ja
meine mail für euch da können wir alle
sind schreibt ihr wollt wenn
irgendwelche ängste habt wenn ihr
irgendwie denkt war mal hier
ob dann tollen tipp für die ich dann wo
es hakt dann können wir das alles hin
schreiben soll ich jetzt mal ganz kurz
hier in der gruft ob hier noch fossilien
sind denke ich weiß nämlich der erste
winter sich mit sich mit ihnen
beschäftigt ich schaue ja keinen anderen
in diesem projekt ihr zu
fossilien dass das in diese blöcke
nachdem ich ausschau halte und jetzt
kann hier nämlich entweder ein relikt
rauskommen oder oder einfach direkten
broken sword das auf komfort legt habe
ich jetzt ich brauche aber fossilien
fossilien wären super cool
schauen wir noch mal eben hier ob in
diesem geschäft hier noch etwas drin ist
ich muss am besten mal wirklich
irgendwie schlucht finden oder nicht
zuviel a
ich weiß wo ich hin kann ich erst mal
kurz die relikte und ich erst mal ganz
kurz zu ende und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier quasi diesem analyzer an diesem
ende leider kann ich jetzt die dinge die
ich aus diesem fonds gerade die ich euch
gezeigt hat wo ich drei von abgebaut
habe kann ich jetzt daran tun dann
passiert daraus eben was da wenn alles
gut läuft wie ich daraus jetzt mal was
was nicht ja dass zum beispiel ein neues
tablet beispielsweise bringt aber auch
nicht so viel
oder halt so ein brocken and sword wenn
ich so ein brocken engines ort quasi
habe kann ich das in ein archäologie
work table dass wenn sich einfach da den
muss ich machen dass es einfach ein
crafting tablet papier
die kann ich vielleicht sogar jetzt eben
machen hab ich weiß nicht gerade gar
nicht papiere habe habe ich oder kann
ich aus einem buch so kraft habe ich
mich irgendwie mal zuckerrohr
mitgenommen oder irgendwie service habe
ich nicht weil ich nur immer in der
suche war nach da war ich immer hier
finde ich immer nur bambus naja
ich schaue mal ganz kurz ich wollte
nämlich da hinten hin wo diese coolen da
waren diese vier schluchten ineinander
da fliegen direkt darauf zu
jedenfalls kann ich in diesen analyzer
halte diese relikte ausmachen reinpacken
oder diese fonds ihre sachen die ich aus
diesem ort rauskriegen bei dem fossil
sachen damit möchte mich als erstes
beschäftigen kriege ich in einer 25
prozentigen chance ein dino eine dino
dna diese dino dna packe ich mit milch
zusammen mit milch betreibe ich den
kalte wetter in den kalten welt herein
und dann besteht die chance dass sich
daraus oder das heißt es besteht die
chance
ich weiß nicht besteht eine chance zu
100 prozent selbst hat gar nicht so
sicher
jedenfalls kann da oder sollte da ich
hoffe mal einfach dass dort dann eine
dino dr
dino herauskommen das kann einfach ingo
hinsetzen und dann habe ich später auch
noch irgendwann meine die domain den op
di ab wofür ich einfach zucker brauchen
weil ich da einfach nicht sogar auf will
dann brauche ich einfach ein buch und
eine dna für aber die dna brauche ich
erstmal durch das ist sehr schön die dna
brauche ich ja erst mal um überhaupt das
ganze zum laufen zu bringen also ich
weiß auf jeden fall was ich jetzt mache
in diesem projekt wie ich vorhin gehen
werde wenn ihr tipps bezüglich der
fossil archäologie motto das ist die
band mit der ich mich dann beschäftigen
werde habt schreibt mir von mir aus in
die kommentare würde ich mich sehr
darüber freuen ich freue mich über jeden
kommentar auch wenn ihr einfach mal
schreiben für gratiskarten sind wirklich
auch super freuen weil ich erfahre ich
sehe dass ihr aktiv sei das eben meine
videos schaut zusätzliche wieder ultra
gyan
da sind um einen gott der rammelt
einfach die prim
soll hier sind fossilien können leider
ähnlich brasilien raus kam ein gott der
kommune sind schwachsinn raus hier
da kommt jetzt immer nur sondern relikt
aus religious religiös sind zwar auch
cool aber ich brauche auch fossilien
jetzt keiner nicht mal vorserien raus
kompalla war formal schreiben die
aufnahmen die vollidioten soll es da
dass man fossilien ganz viele fossilien
ich will nicht überziehen aber ich will
so gerne weitermachen
hey glas schmeckt erst mal weg komplett
weg der euch mal weg ja ich habe drei
fossilien das ist ja schon mal ein
bisschen hallo ich will dass neda ist
ein fossil da sollst du nicht
explodieren
ich war meine ak mitgenommen
scheiße hätten meine ak mitgenommen das
ist ja quasi mit mainz weiter bogen so
geil da sind noch mehr forcieren ich
will eigentlich weiter augsburg gesagt
dass wir am aufnehmen
geil geil geil geil geil ich habe zwei
zilien enttäuscht ich kann jetzt direkt
wieder nach hause fliegen
das wäre so schön wenn jetzt noch auf
dem weg in die zuckerrohr kriegen würde
wahrscheinlich haben sie wieder die
hälfte aller zuschauer irgendwo schon
gesehen wo es rumsteht
ich will einfach zu blöd zu finden naja
ist das geil freunde ist das geil
das ist doch mal sehr sehr schön da
können wir jetzt bald richtig loslegen
ihr wieso kann ich jetzt ein sammelplatz
ja freut mich dass dann kann ich mir ein
kräftiger machen kann ich mir mit dem
fossilen die op dia machen da schon
wächst auch irgendetwas komisches ja
geil freut mich freu mich freuen ich
freue mich sehr sehr schön finde ich
dass übrigens dank an alle die
geschrieben dass da oben zu sonnig und
krankhafter wohnen werde ich den ball
erst an schulter in schreiben dass ich
hier der untermieter bin und das ist
dann keine geräusche abends hören will
so jedenfalls zeige ich euch jetzt mal
was passiert wenn ich ihn nicht in denen
analyzer sondern wenn ich in der laizer
mal fast in den reihen tour 1 nicht noch
mal ganz kurz wieder raus aus dem mache
ich mir nämlich meine meine deen op die
hier zeigt auch das muss ja mit einer
dna machen ich vollidioten guckt da habe
ich die chance wieder verpasst bauen wir
bräunig das sind
ernst breuer auch nicht ich zum thema
eben ganz gut wieder hier bevor ich hier
wieder zehn millionenfach voll bin ja
ich werde bald noch mehr sortieren hier
noch alles mögliche china fans jetzt
mein gott da muss etwas vernünftiges
herauskommt
diese 25 prozent chance will mich
verarschen affären sieht geben doch
einfach überzogen mitmachen
wieso kriegt der luft
das kann ich damit fahren seeds machen
möchte ich irgendwie drauf könnte darauf
an pflanzen liefern machen hier wird
nichts ändert wird ist ein los mit den
fans
mit denen irgendwas machen was bringen
mir fern sieht schreibt smith justiz
bringen kann ich die in den kanal
ich werde jetzt diese folge ich habe auf
jeden fall diese paar sachen schon
geschafft ich werde dann in der nächsten
folge werde ich mir dann einfach das
zuckerrohr und mir daraus dann papier
herstellen und mir aus diesem papier
dann einen ja das mache ich in der
nächsten folge soll ist eine archäologie
kräftig tablet table und mit dem kann
ich dann beispielsweise wenn ich hier
einen brocken engines 23 uhr und hier
reliquien dann kann ich das nachher zu
einem engines ort machen und das gleich
geht dann auch mit helmen weil ich hab
damit global von blogger schon hell mir
da hab ich noch ein brocken entstehen
wärme da auch aber das ist jetzt auch
eine scheiß egal
dafür braucht jeden fall noch viel mehr
religion ich muss noch viel viel mehr
fossilien finden aber ich glaube es ist
geil und balten laufen wir die ersten
die nuss rum wenn euch das gefällt und
durch das gefällt das hardtail table
okay ich das alles gefällt derzeit mit
einer bewertung trips in die kommentare
oder com kräfte gmail.com